bon je voudrais
saluant
jacques de saint victor et jean pierre
rioux en saluant vous qui êtes là et
surtout ceux qui sont là-bas derrière
internet qui vont nous suivre par
internet car ce que vous voyez là n'est
que la partie émergée de notre iceberg
chaleureux maïs berck chaleureux mais
je voudrais vous donner une précision je
vous assure que quand nous avons défini
le sujet
de l'étude des mafias dans les
démocraties contemporaines nous n'avions
aucune information
et aucune arrière-pensée
simplement le phénomène nous intéressait
jean pierre rioux est très
amis familier de jacques de saint victor
en tout cas c'est ce qu'il nous a laissé
entendre
et donc voilà c'est une rencontre
2-2 hasard mais le hasard existe-t-il
c'est une grande question quand tout cas
pour moi je ne résoudrai pas devant vous
ce soir
quelques mots de présentation de jacques
de saint victor autant que je puisse le
connaître alors c'est un c'est un
personnage bizarre
intellectuellement personnages bizarres
humaine dans j'en sais rien on verra
vous jugera on jugera sur pièces
c'est un personnage bizarre parce qu'il
a
beaucoup de cordes à son arc
officiellement
publiquement il est
universitaire et historien des idées
et donc et à ce titre
enseignant à l'université professeur des
universités tout ce qui a de respectable
parallèlement
il est critique littéraire ce qui l'est
un peu moins
accessoirement il est romancier
avec un roman qui s'appelle couple
interdite alors c'est pas pour faire le
lien entre des affaires récentes les
mafias
mais je n'ai rien dit et rien tension
surtout mais couple interdite qui est au
fond une
visite
contemporaine de
1984 ou du meilleur des mondes
ces livres qui décrivent
une évolution de des sociétés et des
tentations que certains ont sur les
sociétés et donc couple interdit ça
raconte
l'histoire de
en
2163 ou quelque chose de cet ordre le
couple est interdite est devenu interdit
mais y'a des nostalgiques du couple la
fidélité est très mal vu et même
interdite mais il y a des nostalgiques
de la finalité est donc
c'est à partir de là que jacques de
saint victor construit son roman ça
c'est pour la partie
comment dirais-je pour eux peu
recommandables de son oeuvre mais il ya
une partie très recommandable alors en
trois chapitres
historien des idées et historien de la
naissance des idées libérales
au fond
fin du xviie fin du xviiie 16 189 1789
quelque chose de cet ordre la naissance
des idées libérales au sens
plein et éminent du terme libéral
qui est en france si mal compris c'est
pas notre sujet de la sans doute en
raison du voyage que les idées libérales
du fonds faire dans l'histoire
française de là il va être l'historien
de la fin de la monarchie absolue
de la du barry jusque à la chute de la
monarchie au testament 2016 enfin est
donc deuxième aspect des choses alors
comment en est il arrivé
l'histoire des idées libérales
de la chute de la monarchie absolue ce
grand tournant de l'histoire française
comment en est il arrivé à analyser la
place le rôle la méthode des mafias dans
les démocraties et notamment en
regardant de près comment les mafias
sont liées
au libéralisme du laisser-faire un
certain désordre qui existe dans les
démocraties à certaines organisations de
l'état
ce qu'on croit toujours que l'état lutte
contre les démocraties il arrive que les
déclins
que l'état lutte contre les mafias il
arrive que les mafias s'installe au
coeur de l'état les mêmes ça c'est vu
assez souvent et donc voilà 7 7 alors je
ne sais pas le secret du du voyage de
l'un à l'autre mais c'est évidemment à
ce titre qu'il est professeur invité à
l'université de rome est donc ce sujet
est très intéressant je veux dire juste
un mot en forme d'inquiétude
les mafias
ça n'est pas seulement un phénomène
des pays étrangers ou limitrophes de la
france
les mafias ça n'est pas seulement un
phénomène insulaires
et j'habite à ce qu'on réfléchisse à ça
je veux pas en dire plus parce que je
veux pas créer de polémique publique
mais moi je pense qu'il y a des des
parties entières du territoire français
qui sont menacés de todd du territoire
français hexagonale du territoire
français continental
qui sont menacés par des pratiques de 7
ans et donc et même pas seulement sous
des latitudes méridionale
méridionale orientale parce que
méridionale occidentale là pour
l'instant grâce à dieu
il ya des pyrénées il ya des démocrates
de partout voilà mes sites
géographiquement intéressant mais il
suffirait de faire des voyages dans le
grand ensemble de l'île de france pour
comprendre que ça n'est pas totalement
éloignée d'un certain nombre de
pratiques voilà je vous remercie d'être
là et je vous remercie d'accueillir
la présentation de jean pierre rioux et
l'intervention de jacques de saint
victor
je ne vais pas faire une longue
présentation
françois bayrou a tout dit sur jacques
de saint victor historiens du droit
historien du libéralisme professeur des
universités il enseigne et à paris 8 et
arômes trois
jeux juste vous dire un mot de son avant
dernier livre parce qu'il nous intéresse
il faut sauver le petit bourgeois
il faut sauver le petit bourgeois et
jacques de saint victor à hull danse de
tout petit livre la force durée
historique et historienne de reprendre
ce vocable anciens noyer aujourd'hui
danse où les notions soit 2,2 en gros
deux classes moyennes ou de certaines
strates des classes moyennes et là vous
verrez il y dit donc le livre est paru
en 2009 je me souviens bien il est
épuisé à faut faire vite et
il est ils
expriment très clairement ce qui est une
chez lui constant ne pas ne confondons
pas la grandeur du libéralisme en
version tocqueville si je puis dire avec
avec ce qu'il appelle après croce le
libéralisme n'est ce pas des chicago
boys n'est ce pas de tous de tous les
continents n'est ce pas et avec cette
espèce d'ultra luzzi père de
postes libéralisme qui ne qui nous
assaillent et qui dérègle tant de choses
aujourd'hui et dans cette perspective là
ce petit lit dit écoutez il y à une
marque il ya à la fois une fragilisation
des classes moyennes y compris en france
et ô combien et le mot classe moyenne a
disparu du vocabulaire politique depuis
quelques mois quelques années
il y as fragilisation et pire il y as
marginalisation dans je dirais dans le
temps dans la vie des cités or bien
entendu on a construit une
représentation qui fait de ces classes
moyennes le groupe central et décisif
d'entraînement d'aider des progrès des
évolutions démocratiques bon je n'en dis
pas plus donc le livre aujourd'hui un
pouvoir invisible les mafias et la
société démocratique
19e 21e siècle c'est un effort
considérable parce que c'est la première
fois que vous avez en français un livre
reprenant le fil depuis le début depuis
l'italie de deux souches c'est la
première histoire politique avant on
avait des histoires secrètes on a une
sorte de gangsters on avait très beau
film on avait du romancier on en avait
du polar on avait tout ce que l'on
voulait là vous avez de là vous avez du
solide après une investigation
historienne qui a été assez assez hard
si j'ai bien lu il
a quand même compulser cordes d'été des
tonnes de documents delà de la police et
de la justice italienne notamment et au
fond
cette histoire politique des doux sur
une inquiétude on peut en sauver ou
viens de parler à l'instant
parce que sa troisième partie du livre
s'intitule la mondialisation comme
triomphe de l'esprit prédateurs et avec
page 14 j'en reste là quand même un
avertissement qui rejoint ce que disait
françois l'instant au point qu'il existe
aujourd'hui des pratiques mafieuses
indépendante des structures mafieuses
elle commence à contaminer des pays
comme la france qui se croyait jusque là
épargnée voilà je n'en dis pas plus
jamais vous avez la parole
bien merci
au président verrous et à jean-pierre de
cette présentation un peu large donc on
va peut-être se limiter à la question du
thème d'aujourd'hui sur les mafias mais
si vous les joueurs parler aussi du
petit bourgeois même si c'est devenu
peut-être une antienne aujourd'hui de la
crise des classes moyennes mais quand il
est écrit c'était au juste au moment du
début de la crise et je crois que
c'est un livre qui a su qu'elle a su
toucher un point qui hélas aujourd'hui
est centrale je voudrais commencer
finalement en répondant à à ce que
françois bayroux demander c'est comment
on passe en effet d'une histoire au fond
de l'ancien régime du libéralisme
commençant à la question des mafias
j'aurais en effet préféré rester toute
ma vie un pont spécialiste de la
question du libéralisme mais ce qui
m'est apparue au fur et à mesure de mes
travaux c'est que évidemment on pouvait
pas se contenter d'étudier libéralisme à
sa naissance on connaît pas le
libéralisme aujourd'hui et au fur et à
mesure des années 2000 il ya une telle
évolution du libéralisme une telle
déviance il voulait d'un certain nombre
de non seulement de pratique mais aussi
de l'idéologie libérale
que j'ai commencé à m'intéresser à un
point qui me semblait central dans la
critique qu'on pouvait faire de cette
dérive et qui était justement cette
question très longtemps occultée dans la
théorie libérale encore aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs qui est la question de la
violence du crime organisé des dérives
de 7
disons de cette organisation de la
société qui ne tient pas compte de la
question
du crime organisé et de la mafia aux
particuliers je me suis intéressé à ça
parce que si vous voulez dans les débats
qu'on a en général face à cette
idéologie
libériste ou néolibérale enfin bon peu
importe les termes
un des éléments que l'on lui au plus
généralement et la question de
l'injustice sociale le problème c'est
que si on si on aborde ce terrain il est
extrêmement minet puisque comme vous le
savez peut-être hayek a énormément
développé la question de la de la non
pertinence du thème de l'injustice
sociale donc c'est un thème si vous
voulez qui d'un point de vue théorique
est très délicat à aborder en revanche
la question du crime la question de
crime organisé la question des dérives
2d société néolibérale en particulier
avec la mondialisation
la montée des problèmes liés à la
corruption enfin bref tous ces thèmes ce
que les néolibéraux classe d'une manière
assez nonchalant tu sous le terme de
externalités négatives
tous ces points ne sont pas très bien
maîtrisé ni analysés par la théorie
néolibérale donc il était intéressant
d'essayer de voir s'il y avait peut-être
un lien entre eux cette mondialisation
dit néolibérale et l'évolution de ces
phénomènes de criminalité organisée
alors c'était un peu le pari de départ
pour essayer de voir si en effet il y
avait il y avait vraiment quelque chose
à attirer de 2,7 de ce présupposé alors
je vais aller très très vite puisque je
pense que le mieux serait peut être de
laisser aussi des questions je crois que
c'est l'idée alors je voudrais quand
même exposé oui je vais je vais quand
même essayer de montrer que la question
de la mafia a généralement été traités
en particulier en france comme une
question soit de nature journalistique
soit une question de nature assez
secondaire c'est à dire que l toucher
aux questions dites de sécurité sécurité
publique mais en aucun cas aux questions
touchant au coeur même de la démocratie
alors en réalité on le voit bien
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs dans la confusion
actuelle qui règne dans le débat
qui a explosé à propos de la sphère
cahuzac on entend un peu tout et
n'importe quoi on voit très bien qu'en
effet la la la la la question de la
mafia et je la définirait ensuite
l'autorisé la question de la mafia pose
deux problèmes essentiels à la à la
démocratie d'abord elle corrompt les
pratiques traditionnelles de la
démocratie c'est à dire qu'au fond elle
rend les règles du jeu réel très
différente de des règles du jeu
théorique enfin telles qu'elles sont
présentées dans les cours dans les
livres tel qu'on nous
résume ce qu'est le la promesse de la
démocratie donc on se réveille un jour
en se disant et en comprenant ou en
pensant comprendre que les règles du jeu
sont pas du tout celles que les les
discours officiels nous nous nous
prétendent être et donc c'est le
deuxième effet ensuite les phénomène
mafieux introduisent un autre élément
dans la règle du jeu démocratique
c'est que elle crée généralement des
réaction désespérée et des réactions
populistes je crois que par exemple nous
avons un pays dont je vous avais eu la
gentillesse de préciser que j'y enseigne
l'italie qui est comme souvent un très
bon laboratoire politique et on voit
très bien en italie ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui
après vingt ans de berlusconisme on a
une situation absolument je dirais
politiquement bloqués et dramatique
parce qu'on a vu l'émergence d'un
phénomène très neuf dans le paysage
disons politiques européens c'est-à-dire
une sorte de d'émergence d'un populisme
comment le qualifier vaguement de gauche
mais en tout cas hostile à tout ce qui y
est la partitocratie que ce soit
d'ailleurs les partis de droite comme
les partis de gauche et qui est
constituée avec ce fameux acteur
comédien qu'on a maladroitement je crois
comparer en france à coluche c'est
plutôt un mélange de
dinde une sorte de jacques cheminade
avec besancenot si vous laissez c'est
plutôt ce mélange là qui résumerait ce
qu'est grillo et ça eh bien c'est la
conséquence directe
paradoxalement un peu c'est vrai des
purges de monsieur montpetit qui a été
assez maladroit concrètement il était
assez mal présentée en france mais il
n'a pas été extrêmement populaire en
italie évidemment c'est difficile de
faire populaire quand on fait ses
réformes et il n'y a peut-être pas eu la
manière il n'a pas su les faire mais
c'est surtout la conséquence de 20 ans
de corruption et j'ai pour des raisons
particulières assisté à toute la
campagne électorale italienne le seul
thème alors que vous savez combien
l'italie est un pays avec une dette
colossale plus de 120% du pib enfin
c'est quelque chose de très préoccupant
et bien leeds arguments économiques
étaient totalement absents de la
campagne électorale à part mon team et
qui n'a pas su se faire entendre les
arguments essentiels tourner autour de
la corruption de la partitocratie et de
la fameuse caste phenom terme qu'on
commence petit à petit à voir ici
et il faut donc être très attentes
attentif et même très
dirais-je faire très attention à
l'utilisation qu'on va faire aujourd'hui
du de tous les termes et dé tous les
concepts qu'ils vont naître de cette
crise actuelle que l'on traverse en
france parce que j'entends notamment
trait de plus en plus utilisé
l'expression il faut faire une opération
mains propres à la française je vous
rappelle oui peut-être mais ne nous
leurrons pas les conséquences de
l'opération mani pulite et en italie ça
a été un an plus tard le triomphe de
berlusconi c'est à dire l'inversé exact
de ce pour quoi
les gens en 1991 en 1992 protestait on
pourrait revenir c'est pas le propos
mais il faut donc bien comprendre qu'en
effet il ya un lien très étroit entre
des phénomènes de corruption de haut
niveau et la crise de la démocratie
alors pourquoi la mafia et bien entendu
il ne faut pas faire de confusion
les phénomènes comme par exemple cahuzac
les les éléments de compréhension corps
comme des éléments de corruption n'ont
rien à voir avec des phénomènes mafieux
je pourrais je pense on si on veut y
revenir mais je vais mourir est limité
aux questions mafieux stricto sensu mais
on peut faire une échelle de graduation
1 entre la corruption simple et puis la
grande corruption
de type mafieuse en passant par les
phénomènes de criminalité en col blanc
les phénomènes de corporates crème etc
etc pour rien tout une graduation sous
les jeux on pourra on pourra y revenir
la mafia qu'est ce que c'est je voudrais
la définir très brièvement avec vous
ensuite essayez d'examiner en quoi
justement elle était un troc intriqués
comme terme est un peu un jargon mais
les ongles 500 utilisent souvent ça
entre kate avec les phénomènes
démocratique parce que justement les
mafias prospère beaucoup mieux dans les
pays démocratiques que dans les
dictatures ce qui ne doit pas nous
amener à vouloir je ne crois pas en tout
cas c'est pas mon propos vous proposer
comme solution la dictature pour lutter
contre la mafia ça serait évidemment
catastrophique
et puis dans un troisième point et je
répondrai un peu peut-être de manière
brève mais
historiquement
j'essaierai d'aborder avec vous la
question française parce que justement
je partage tout à fait ce que vous venez
de dire et je crois qu'il ya une clé de
lecture qui manque en france et qui est
très facile à utiliser pour saisir ce
qu'est la situation française alors
d'abord qu'est-ce que la mafia il faut
il faut partir de l'italie pourquoi
parce que d'abord les italiens
contrairement aux français contrairement
aux allemands contrairement aux anglais
les italiens sont avec les américains
les seuls qui ont une réflexion
extrêmement aboutie sur le phénomène
mafieux vous me direz c'est normal que
ce soient les états unis où que ce soit
l'italie ce sont des pays qui
connaissent depuis très longtemps la
question mafieuse pas seulement je pense
que des pays qui ont des difficultés
comme les nôtres ont connu si on remonte
dans l'histoire des phénomènes très
proches ou en tout cas assez
sensiblement proches à des phénomènes
mafieux mais du fait de leur histoire
particulière ils ne les ont pas abordés
l'italie a
eu la chance et je mets des guillemets
parce que ça a été un moment absolument
dramatique dans son histoire au moment
d'aller des années 70 et dans les années
80 a la chance d'avoir une mafia qui
s'est transformé en une sorte de
phénomène terroriste c'est à dire que l
a commencé à poser des bombes
tout le monde a entendu parler ici de ce
qui s'est passé à palerme dans les
années 80 bref tout le monde a eu
l'image de la mafia comme un phénomène
extrêmement sanguinaire extrêmement
brutal et violent en réalité ça a été
une étape une une brève époque dans le
phénomène mafieux qui a d'ailleurs
plutôt conduit la mafia sicilienne à se
marginaliser parce que il y a eu une
réaction très forte de l'état et cette
réaction très forte a été à la fois sur
le plan répressif bien entendu mais elle
a été aussi sur le plan législatif et
l'italie est le seul pays en europe qui
a un article de son code pénal qui
définit ce qu'est une mafia alors je
vais pas vous faire un cours jeu de
droit ce n'est pas le propos mais il
faut ce qu'il faut en retenir l'idée que
l'article 416 bis du code pénal italien
précise que la maintien c'est d'abord
une structure qui utilise des méthodes
violentes mais c'est d'abord et avant
tout par le fait qu'elle a la puissance
du lien associatif c'est une traduction
un peu maladroite mais c'est le lien
associatif qui crée la puissance de la
mafia c'est à dire le fait que justement
il ya là on parle d'ailleurs d'une
association mafieuse c'est à dire qu'on
traduit un un phénomène meta juridique
l'organisation est
là la mafia vous voulez en un terme
juridique proprement dit qui est l'
association mafieuse alors cette
association mafieuse
7 elle est née
précisément bon c'est difficile de
donner une date évidemment exacte mais
elle est né en sicile au début du 19e
siècle lors de ce moment de transition
justement entre l'économie d'ancien
régime qui est il une économie très
administrée et le début de l'économie
capitaliste
cette transition a été extrêmement
rapide et brutale en sicile là où comme
vous le savez en angleterre ou en france
elle s'est fait sur dix ont un ou deux
voire plusieurs siècles donc il y a eu
une habitude et finalement nous n'avons
pas connu en france ni en angleterre ces
phénomènes que la sicile va connaître au
début du 19e siècle je rentre pas dans
les détails mais je vous donne un cas
précis pour comprendre comment un une
transition qui se passe de façon trop
brutale entraîne des phénomènes de
violence qui génère à leur tour des
besoins de protection
et c'est dans ce besoin de protection
que naît le phénomène mafieux car il
faut bien comprendre la mafia n'a rien à
voir le phénomène mafieux ou de
criminalité organisée de haut niveau n'a
rien à voir avec le banditisme
traditionnel le banditisme traditionnel
qui existe depuis l'origine de
l'humanité en tout cas de l'histoire
c'est les pirates de l'époque
d'alexandre c'est robin des bois c'est
mandrin ses cartouches etc ces
phénomènes de banditisme sont des
phénomènes marque de marginalité
il généralement d'ailleurs les bandits
viennent de milieux extrêmement modestes
lorsque l'on regarde la naissance du
phénomène mafieux on est au contraire
très surpris de groupes de voir que ce
ne sont pas des gens margie o qui
constituent les premières associations
criminelle
en sicile au début du 19e siècle ce qui
constitue les premières associations
criminels sont généralement ce qu'un
auteur de l'époque qui les a bien
examiné et que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui grâce aux juges falcone qui
l'a sorti des des vieilles bibliothèque
poussiéreuse où seuls les pauses
universitaires comme moi vont encore
se ce baron franck éthique qui avait
étudié en 1877 le phénomène mafieux qui
déjà était un peu structurée en sicile
eh bien il comprend que c'est la
bourgeoisie de palerme pas tout
évidemment ne généralisons pas mais ceux
qui sont à la tête de ces associations
mafieuses ce sont des bourgeois et il
parle à ce moment-là il créé le concept
très neuf de démocratisation de la
violence qu'est ce que ça veut dire la
démocratisation de la violence ça veut
pas du tout dire que la violence et
démocratique où s'est démocratisée
puisque je vous dis depuis toujours les
les gens modestes utilisent la violence
non la démocratisation de la violence ça
veut dire des classes que l'on pensait
que toute la philosophie libérale
pensait être des classes
laborieuses et paisible c'est à dire la
bourgeoisie qui par rapport à
l'aristocratie féodal qui était une
aristocratie qui avait fondé sa
puissance sur la prédation
et bien la bourgeoisie commerçante au
contraire c'était un espoir de créer une
société nouvelle fondée sur des rapports
paisible et c'est d'ailleurs ce qui
s'est passé on pourrait discuter ici de
l'histoire du capitalisme mais enfin
c'est grosso modo ce qui s'est passé
dans certains pays comme l'angleterre ou
la france ce n'est pas ce qui s'est
passé justement aussi la transition
s'est faite au profit d'une bourgeoisie
qui a repris les vieilles méthodes
prédatrice de l'ancien élu féodal et
elle s'est constituée en dix ans des
groupes ce qu'on appelait à l'époque des
frappes elle lance ou des sectes qui
petit à petit au compris et je prends
exprès les expressions de adam smith
pour comprendre à quel point elles ont
été déviés elles ont compris que la main
invisible du crime était encore plus
efficace que la main invisible du marché
et c'est à la suite de cette réflexion
d'ailleurs intellectuelle de la part
d'un certain nombre de ses dirigeants
des sectes mafieuses ou pré mafieuse
puisqu'il y en a un un baron d'ailleurs
qui se réclament justement de mandeville
lui même le fameux mandeville de la
fable des abeilles qui au fond dit que
le le le les vices privés font le bien
public
car ce ne sont pas des gens qui à
l'origine de cette mafia sont des
ignorants et d'ailleurs tout le folklore
mafieux
l'intronisation les règles les codes il
ya des codes mafieux qui sont écrits
comme des codes juridiques le l'univers
dans lequel la mafia s'inscrit les
références généralement à des vieux
phénomène très anciens comme par exemple
les chevaliers sicilia qui aurait été à
l'origine du terme même de mafia etc etc
tous est tout ce folklore est un
folklore bourgeois pour ne pas même dire
aristocratique des simples associations
dandy ne pense pas à se réclamer d'une
origine aussi antique est aussi est
aussi particulière bref tout cela pour
dire donc ce sont des associations qui à
la base sont des associations de
possédants et qu'ils ont compris qu au
moment où justement on démocratise et où
on essayait de pacifier avec le commerce
avec la nouvelle société capitaliste
pacifier les moeurs que là et bien qu'il
était possible d'utiliser des armes
particulière pour s'insérer et gagner
dans la nouvelle commercial society pour
reprendre l'expression à la mode au à la
fin du xviiie siècle
donc il ya eu dès le départ un lien avec
le capitalisme naissant dans ces régions
dix ont reculé du sud de l'italie il ya
d'autres explications bien entendu
notamment anthropologique et autres mais
si vous voulez je vais très très vite et
puis assez rapidement à partir de la fin
du 19e siècle on s'est rendu compte que
la mafia à bootsie prospérer avec la
démocratie ça c'est le deuxième deuxième
élément après le capitalisme la
démocratie parce que la démocratie lui a
offert au fond la possibilité
de s'insérer entièrement dans le jeu
politique dans le jeu politique local et
voire parfois dans le jeu politique
national parce que tant que le jeu
politique était extrêmement limité la
l'italie jusqu'en 1914 jusqu'en 1912 n'a
pas connu le suffrage universel c'était
un suffrage censitaire et jusqu en 1882
c'est une insulte rage ultra censitaire
du style de celui que nous avions en
france sous la restauration donc c'est
un suffrage qui ne permettait pas même
aux classes moyennes
bruay et est issu les premiers
fondateurs de ces secte mafieuse cela ne
leur permettait pas d'entrer dans le jeu
politique donc quand c'est ouvert à
partir des années 1880 le jeu politique
eh bien nous on voit immédiatement que
ce soit en calabre que ce soit à naples
que ce soit en sicile eh bien on voit
ces secte mafieuse
entrer dans le jeu politique soit comme
d'hab' comme simple appui
avec notamment les systèmes dits de
clientélisme soit directement comme
acteurs du jeu politique et c'est
d'ailleurs à cette époque là qu'on voit
apparaître des nouveaux termes pour
désigner ces phénomènes si singulier on
va parler désormais de haute mafia ou de
mafia ingram djallit de mafia en beurre
frais c'est à dire au fond pour désigner
tout un appareil politique désormais
soin et membres des associations
mafieuses soit et c'est le plus beau
fréquents et en lien avec ces
associations mafieuses pour faire des
affaires les phénomènes sont très
célèbres et ont été extrêmement bien
étudié à la fois par la justice et
ensuite par les historiens pour naples
pour palerme est aussi même si c'était
moins - nec pour la calabre bon
alors je vais très très vite ce
phénomène ces phénomènes montre une
chose que résume très bien le fils du
général della chiesa qui est un
sociologue de milan il dit la force de
la mafia ne vit pas dans la mafia mais j
en dehors de la mafia et elle gît
justement dans les appareils politiques
économiques sportif médiatique etc etc
qui lui apporte son pouvoir et c'est est
ce qu avait très bien compris justement
à la fois franck et y le fameux baron
qui étudie au début de des années 1870
le phénomène mafieux en sicile est ce qu
avait aussi très bien compris le juge
falcone fameux juge que vous donc
j'imagine tout le monde a vaguement
entendu parler qui est mort assassiné
par par la mafia en 1992 les falcons
avaient justement élaboré une théorie
juridique qui devait permettre pour lui
de
d'attaquer de manière efficace le
phénomène mafieux c'est à dire on
pouvait pas se contenter d'attaqué
uniquement ceux qui justement mettez des
bombes ou qu'ils tuaient des gens ou qui
dissolvait les enfants dans l'acide etc
bref toutes les méthodes que l'on a un
peu connu et qui font le folklore
mafieux enfin un folklore ce sanguinaire
et terribles mais mais qui n'est qu'un
folklore qui n'est qu'une apparence qui
n'est que la surface des choses ce qu'il
fallait c'est essayer de s'attaquer à la
réalité de ceux de ces zones grises qui
constituait la véritable force de la
mafia et il est mort trop tôt puisque il
a justement été nommé à rome
à la tête du ministre du direction des
affaires pénales pour essayer justement
d'élaborer ces armes juridiques qui
permettraient de remonter jusqu'à ses
mandants ou ses bénéficiaires du
phénomène mafieux il est mort justement
en 1992 avant d'avoir mettre en place
cette nouvelle législation et elle a été
heureusement reprises par la cour de
cassation en 1994 qui a créé un concept
que vous retrouver au coeur de toutes
les affaires les grandes affaires qui
ont touché à la fois andreotti qui ont
touché berlusconi qui ont touché des
loteries qui ont touché et c'est ça qui
est le concept de concours externe en
association mafieuse qu'on peut traduire
en français comme complicité avec l'
association mafieuse c'est ce concept
que nous n'avons pas du tout en france
et qui rend évidemment beaucoup plus
délicat l'action de
répressive face à des phénomènes qui
aujourd'hui apparaissent de plus en plus
et c'est mon dernier point égyptiens
comme des phénomènes mathieu alors
yat-il c'est la grande question que la
chaque fois on pose y at il une mafia en
france où il y at il des mafias en
france là la réalité du phénomène
français a très longtemps échappé à la
fois où je dirais aux experts au savon
criminologue et autres parce que
il y as souvent unis auront sur ce
qu'est exactement aujourd'hui surtout
depuis la mondialisation la
le système mafieux en lui même il faut
bien distinguer c'est une distraction
d'un grand criminologue américain qui
s'appelle alan bloc ce que l'on appelle
le power syndicate est l'auteur price
syndicate c'est à dire le pouvoir le
power syndiqués cesser le pouvoir d'une
organisation qui contrôle un territoire
et ça il est vrai qu'en france jusque
dans les années 80
cela n'a pas existé ou quand cela a
existé il suffit de songer à marseille
dans les années 30 cela a été assez
limitées dans le temps et finalement ce
phénomène n'est pas apparue comme
marquant
les historiens pour les sociologues pour
ceux qui étudient c'est ce type de
phénomène en revanche si on se place du
côté de l'entente price indique est
c'est à dire long les réseaux de trafic
qui touche à la fois au monde de
l'activité économique légale est
évidemment illégal je pense par exemple
au trafic de drogue il faut savoir que
les français en l'espèce ce que l'on
appelle les corso marseillais ont été
depuis les années 30 à la pointe de ces
phénomènes d'entreprise indique m tout
le monde a entendu parler parce que ça a
été utilisée voilà par les américains la
fameuse french connection qui est en
réalité un phénomène extrêmement
complexe mais ce sont des réseaux corses
corso-marseillais donc qui depuis les
années 30 ont constitué une immense
toile qui va de saigon
shanghai
turquie
bref tous les endroits où il y a des de
l'opium jusque dans jusqu aux états unis
et je les dis ce depuis les années 30 et
ça a repris de plus belle depuis les
années 50 jusqu'aux disons aux années 70
cette french connection souligne à quel
point il y a en effet des réseaux qui
ont été très puissant en france alors
qu'est ce qui s'est passé depuis les
années 80 il ya eu une mutation de ce
phénomène c'est à dire qu' un certain
nombre de ces
réseaux ont été un peu affaibli d'abord
par la concurrence mondiale la
mondialisation du crime crée aussi des
concurrences extrêmement forte entre les
différentes organisations criminelles et
puis il ya eu aussi d'abord la
décolonisation qui a modifié un certain
nombre de choses dont je pourrais y
revenir parce que ça joue beaucoup sur
le phénomène de l'afrique et il y a eu
aussi je conclus en corse là le
phénomène je sais que je ne faire
écharper chez les démocrates mais le
phénomène de la décentralisation qui a
considérablement
rendu
certains territoires alors en effet pas
seulement des territoires insulaires pas
seulement la corse mais aussi la région
paca des zones beaucoup plus propice
pour y faire un certain nombre
d'affaires et pourquoi la
décentralisation joue un rôle dans
l'essor des phénomènes mafieux que l'on
a d'ailleurs très bien connu en sicile
et dans le sud de l'italie où vous le
savez il y a eu une décentralisation
extrêmement poussée depuis au moins les
à les années d'après guerre et bien
parce qu'il est beaucoup plus facile de
cours ont un président de conseil
général qu'un préfet qui ne dépend que
directement de paris pour sa carrière
c'est du b à ba c'est du bea bas à telle
enseigne d'ailleurs que dans la lutte
qu'il a eue qui a voulu mener contre la
corruption mario monti par exemple a
pris des mesures pour revenir sur un
certain nombre de règles concernant la
décentralisation
parce que c'est le triste
constat que l'on peut faire
il y à des régions quand il y a
évidemment de l'argent en de l'argent
important par exemple jusque dans les
années 70 il y avait un double phénomène
pour la corse jusque dans les années
soixante dix la corse n'était pas une
terre riche il y avait rien à faire en
corse les prix de l'immobilier étaient
bas et par conséquent
ses côtes pour reprendre une expression
un peu douteuse c'est quand les prix de
l'immobilier explosent dans tous les
sens du terme partir des années 80 que
la corse devient évidemment là aussi une
zone où il est propice d'investir et par
conséquent se crée à nouveau des
phénomènes
alors multiples parce que évidemment
nous sommes là face à des phénomènes
extrêmes en multiples mais en tout cas
un certain nombre d'anciens de la french
connection de tous ces réseaux se sont
re
tourner en face on retourner en corse et
là un certain nombre ont muté c'est à
dire qu'on n'est plus on ne sait plus
limité aux poppers indiqué qu on est en
train de se transformer par dons
d'entreprises sonic est on est de plus
en plus en train de se transformer en
organisation qui contrôle un territoire
alors on se contrôle un territoire
certains partie de la corse-du-sud dont
une partie de la corse du nord en fait
on en est pas encore arrivé au phénomène
mafieux à la sicilienne ou à la
calabraise qu'est ce qui en fait la
différence la différence vient du fait
qu'en le ce qu'on appelle la nébuleuse
corso marseillaise n'est pas constituée
en organisation pyramidale
structurée de manière aussi précise
il faut imaginer les organisations six
idées donc à la bresse sont quasiment
structurés comme des armes et
ils n'ont pas énormément de soldats
contrairement à ce qu'on peut imaginer
on n'a guère plus de 6000 le soldat en
sicile et en calabre
enfin 6 il 6 me les calades 6000 donc ça
fait pas beaucoup si vous voulez mais
c'est quand même des structures
extrêmement pyramidale les groupes
corses sont des groupes extrêmement ce
sont des nébuleuses de quelques
personnes peu structuré peut
hiérarchiser n'ayant pas le goût de tout
le folklore dont j'ai parlé ou en tout
cas ne l'ayant pas eu semblant peut-être
maintenant renouer avec un certain
folklore de ce type et surtout ce sont
des groupes
avant tout
tourner vers des logiques d'affaires
mais et c'est là où il faut bien saisir
c'est exactement comme cela que la
criminologie italienne désigne la
camorra car la camorra ce n'est pas une
mafia comme les autres la camorra c'est
la mafia donc napolitaine elle n'est pas
semblable à celle que vous avez
peut-être vu si vous avez vu le film
gomorra scène elle n'est pas semblable à
la mafia sicilienne et la mafia
calabraise est d'ailleurs à naples
maintenant on ne parle plus vraiment de
mafia on parle de au système d'un
système parce qu'en fait ce sont des
petits clans très désorganisée très
fluctuants et bien c'est un peu ça qui
est d'ailleurs c'est ce que la
criminologie italienne désigne quand je
sais ce qui m'avait mis sur la piste des
corses parce que je ne savais pas je ne
connaissais pas l'histoire française si
précises en ce qui concerne les
corso-marseillais ce sont les
criminologues italien qui classent dans
les organisations mafieuses horizontale
comme il dit
la camorra élégant corso marseillais
et c'est que ce qui se passe en corse ou
âme dans la région paca ce n'est pas des
phénomènes de mafia à la sicilienne
c'est des phénomènes de système mafieux
en lien avec des autorités
locales et parfois nationale qui
s'organisent afin de à la fois contrôler
un territoire et surtout comme toute
entorse travail syndical de faire du
business
voilà donc maintenant la parole est à
vous il n'ya qu'une règle comme vous
savez on dépassera pas guéri 8h15 c'est
notre temps de débat est la seule règle
et alternance masculin féminin
bonsoir ça marche oui
alors ma question vous paraîtra
peut-être un peu naïve mais je pense
il ya quelques semaines à l'occasion du
festival de la chanson de san remo il ya
un jeune chanteur qui a remporté le
premier prix pour une chanson qui
s'appelle penza et dont le refrain et
pense c'est toi qui peux décider et
c'est donc ma question est est ce que
vous pensez que à la longue ce début
d'indignation qui est en train de se
d'après les médias en tout cas est en
train de se propager un peu partout
finira par sinon venir à bout de la
pieuvre tout au moins la désorganiser
d'une façon ou d'une autre
alors je voudrais répondre sur deux
points la pieuvre c'est justement je
crois une image assez assez inexact mais
c'est évidemment l'utilisation qu'on en
fait généralement donc ne vous inquiétez
pas mais ça me permet justement de
rebondir la notion pieuvre ça donne une
impression que vraiment il ya des
tentacules partout et qu'on va jamais
s'en sortir je lui préfère dans le livre
la notion de cancer c'est à dire que le
cancer ça attaque des cellules on sait
pas un peu pourquoi et comment parfois
on s'en sort parfois on s'en sort pas
l'exemple que l'on a de l'histoire de
l'implantation mafieuses dans les pays
là on parle d'implantations extérieur
donc
est assez contradictoires il ya parfois
des implantations extrêmement réussie et
il ya aussi des échecs de la mafia faut
pas croire que c'est une organisation
qui rien ne résiste même si elle est
très puissante alors qu'est ce qui se
passe actuellement en italie il ya
évidemment une réaction mais pas depuis
san remo il ya au moins depuis 20 ans
une réaction assez forte l'organisation
de
d'associations antimafia d'associations
qui rackettent il ya une sorte de
société civile anticorruption et anti
mafia qui s'est constitué
le vrai danger
du fait même de l'importance de ces
phénomènes criminels dans la société
italienne le vrai danger c'est de ces
c'est exactement ce qui est en train de
se passer actuellement en italie c'est
de voir la corruption partout et la
mafia partout et c'est exactement
d'ailleurs
parce qu'il y avait eu 20 ans berlusconi
dont on sait par d'ailleurs par la
justice parce que moi je je ne parle
qu'à partir de décision définitive de
justice on sait évidemment que
berlusconi a des liens étroits avec ces
organisations mafieuses et bien les gens
la réaction à l'eau stade et au niveau
individuel et bien c'est le tous pourris
évidemment phénomène que nous nous
craignons aussi pour d'autres raisons
mais qu' on ne peut semble-t-il hélas
pas éviter aujourd'hui alors il y avait
un grand écrivain italien qui s'appelle
leonardo cha cha qui disaient
ces professionnels de l'anti mafias font
aussi beaucoup de tort alors c'était
peut-être exagéré de le dire comme ça
mais il faut en effet faire très
attention c'est à dire que moi j'ai été
frappé dans les études que j'ai pu mener
la manière dont on veut voir la mafia
partout en italie mais c'est logique et
c'est compréhensible parce que elle est
souvent là hélas mais elle n'est pas
toujours là et il ya cette tendance à
l'avoir un peu partout et si vous me
permettez une anecdote personnelle je
discutais avec un des meilleurs avec un
des conseillers de la cour de cassation
italienne qui est le meilleur
spécialiste de la camo l'ajustement il
me disait je suis pas sûr que ce que
j'écris un deuxième livre sur justement
les corso marseillais il m'a dit je suis
pas sûr qu'ils rendent un bon un bon
service à ton pays parce que le résultat
du compte l'opinion connaît trop bien
ces phénomènes c'est qu'elles pensent
après que tout le monde est pourri
toutes les élites sont pourris et ça a
un effet encore plus délétères sur la
démocratie je ne pense pas cela je crois
qu'il faut à un moment crever l'abcès
quand il ya des phénomènes aussi
prégnant et qu'on n'arrive pas à nommer
car on ne peut combattre bien un
phénomène que quand on le connaît bien
mais il ya des risques il faut pas s'en
cacher
masculin mais ça sera moi
enfin je me classe dans cette catégorie
non
juste une précision à votre avis quel
est le degré d'implication
dans aux différentes époques récente
des responsables politiques italiens
engagés ou parrainés c'est l'un ou
l'autre par la mafia j'ai été très
frappée je raconte une anecdote plus que
les mots assez bien la vie politique
italienne est très bien beaucoup de
responsables politiques italiens de la
période récente y compris berlusconi
j'ai été très frappé qu'un certain
nombre d'entre mangeant au restaurant
avec moi
ne disait jamais mafia il disait à voix
basse les cinq lettres
est ma fille comme nous on dit ça pour
des gros mots tu n'as pas le droit de
dire disait tu sais tu vois les singles
être
comme si en effet c'était pour eux un
sentiment que vaut mieux ne pas en
parler dans
les restaurants fréquentés par les
hommes politiques
alors quelle est votre appréciation
du degré d'implication l'a beaucoup dit
pour de grands responsables de la
démocratie chrétienne avant on l'a
beaucoup dit pour des socialistes avant
alors je voudrais savoir votre
appréciation
oui oui non mais de toute façon je
l'évoquent dans le livre donc la
question du phénomène mafieux c'est elle
est très difficile et très difficile d'y
répondre d'une manière quantitative
c'est ce que j'ai aussi expliquer ses
clés il faut hélas admettre et admettre
que comme c'est un chiffre noir il est
là aussi délicat de répondre de manière
définitive au degré d'implication je
peux pas vous dire qu'à 70% de la classe
italienne 40% mais mais
mais il ya eu il ya eu c'est pour ça que
l'on peut euros en francs en italie par
non travaillés de manière assez assez
simple pour un chercheur qui peut pas se
permettre de faire des révélations
samson des fonds souad archives soit
soit des fonds judiciaire et bien il y a
eu de nombreuses de nombreuses
procédures judiciaires qui sont arrivées
jusqu'à la cour de cassation nous
poussons définitive qui ont mis en vide
en évidence alors hausse au niveau local
la mafia est extrêmement bien implantée
dans tout ce qui concerne le mezzogiorno
évidemment est aujourd'hui dans tout ce
qui est aussi le nord de l'italie en
particulier la lombardie et c'est pour
ça que là ça nous touche le piémont et
ça depuis les années 70 il ya même eu un
assassinat d'un des procureurs de turin
parce que justement et il était un peu
ennuyeux pour la mafia donc si vous
voulez
voilà c'est cela la mafia jusqu alors
jusqu'à absolument jusque dans les
années 70 la mafia et terrell vraiment
limité au sud de l'italie elle est
montée parce qu'elle suit le flux d
affaires d affaires au centre du
business l'argent et
elle a touché alors là c'est je restais
au niveau local mais elle a touché le
niveau national et on a eu de nom deux
affaires qui grâce justement aux
concepts juridiques du juge falcone dont
je vous parlais la concours externe une
association mafieuse ont permis de
remonter y compris bien jusqu'au
précédent enfin un des anciens
présidents du conseil italien giulio
andreotti qui mena qui n'a pas s il a
été si vous voulez la l'art est un des
arrêts de la cour de cassation l'air là
ne l'a pas innocenté sous les ailes at
il a dit elle à la cour a décidé que
l'action était prescrite ski pas du tout
la même chose les faits ont été révélés
c'est dans l'histoire bon je pourrais ça
serait un peu long à expliquer mais on
sait qu'il a fait appel à des
organisations mafieuses pour éliminer
quelqu'un d'un journaliste en l'espèce
et les faits ont été considérés comme
prescrits de la même manière pour
berlusconi c'est à dire que en 2012 il
ya eu l'arrêt de la cour de cassation
qui a expliqué que son adjoint direct
marcello dell'utri le sénateur
fondateurs de forza italia le parti de
berlusconi était l'homme qui faisait
jusqu'en 1992 à l'on n'est pas allé au
delà parce qu'après ça devient la partie
politique de l'action berlusconi mais en
tout cas des années 70 jusqu'en 1992
c'était le sénateur dell'utri qui
faisait le lien la jonction entre les
organisations mafieuses de palerme et
berlusconi
donc ça c'est dans des décisions
définitives de la cour de cassation
c'est pas des élucubrations en réalité
qu'est ce qui se passe il se passe qu'on
est face à un phénomène qui a été
souvent très bien décrit et qui
entraînerait d'ailleurs s'il existait
sur le territoire français les mêmes
conséquences c'est-à-dire que dont le
sud de l'italie la mafia est un des
acteurs incontournables
du paysage politique économique et
sociale
il y à ce que les italiens appellent un
besoin de mafia c'est à dire que il ya
une sorte de vide souvent qui s'est
accentuée depuis la crise de l'état
providence et qui est rempli par ces
organisations
et donc un homme politique
jusqu en tout cas très récemment un
homme politique un chef d'entreprise qui
veut faire quelque chose sur le
territoire qui est contrôlé par la mafia
eh bien il est obligé d'une manière ou
d'une autre d'entrée au contact avec
cette mafia est d'ailleurs la
jurisprudence italienne est extrêmement
est extrêmement précises parce que comme
elle sait très bien qu'un territoire qui
est contrôlé par la mafia il n'est pas
possible de faire en dehors de
l'organisation mafieuse et bien elle va
distinguer par exemple c'est pas du tout
la même chose d'être un entrepreneur
soumis et un entrepreneur complices
les autres repreneurs soumise c'est de
toute façon si vous avez un supermarché
dans la région de palerme vous devez
payer le pizzo
et si vous ne payez pas vous avez les
pires ennuis donc c'est on peut pas me
jeter entièrement la pierre même si le
mieux serait de ne pas payer mais
convenue à jeter la pierre à quelqu'un
qui veut protéger sa vie sa famille son
magasin
c'est pas du tout la même chose avec ce
qu'on appelle un entrepreneur complice
ou un politicien complice qui lui va
utiliser dans ce qu'on appelle un vote
des changes un pacte aux 10 cambio qui
est très bien définis par la
jurisprudence italienne entre
l'entrepreneur où le politique et
l'organisation criminelle parce que là
c'est un pacte synallagmatique c'est à
dire que chacun en tire des bénéfices
réciproques et c'est ça qu'il faut
évidemment essayer de de poursuivre et
la classe politique italienne locales et
donc je répondu en partie nationale
évidemment alors attention justement je
t'ai première alerté pas le tous pourris
il ya plein d'hommes politiques italiens
qui sont tout à fait tout à fait honnête
titre personnel je suis je suis marié
avec une députée de milan donc je peux
vous dire qu'elle est totalement en
dehors des phénomènes mafieux
mais bon c'est une dit elle été élu
récemment mais bon bref j'ai pas du tout
vu la mafia dans le moment de la
campagne électorale pourtant on sait
très bien que la mafia est à milan et
surtout la mafia calabraise parce qu'il
ya il ya même milan 2015 qui est en
préparation la grande exposition
universelle et va y avoir énormément il
ya déjà énormément d'affaires qui sont
sortis j'ajouterai un dernier point si
nous savons beaucoup de choses en italie
c'est parce que aussi nos amis italiens
ont une spécificité le parquet en italie
est totalement indépendant et je peux
vous dire que dans les histoires
mafieuse l'indépendance du parquet ou au
contraire ça non dépendance fait une
énorme différence
pour la révélation de la vérité
merci beaucoup
je j'ai scrupuleux peut-être oui ah les
femmes parce que j'aurais pu m'exclure
de cette catégorie mais
une petite question savoir si l'europe
en fait amis des outils pour lutter
activement contre la mafia sachant que
de ce que je sais j'en connais peu mais
elle s'est répandue aussi en allemagne
via notamment chose un petit peu stupide
mais des pizzerias des choses comme ça
est ce qu elle pour blanchir l'argent
est ce qu'elle est un moyen efficace en
fait de lutter contre ces réseaux alors
sur les réseaux il ya énormément de
choses sur la mafia stricto sensu lé
l'europe essaye de faire de sensibiliser
des pays comme la france comme
l'allemagne justement pour faire adopter
le délit d'association mafieuse mais
c'est très délicat parce que justement
comme je venais de le dire des pays qui
ne l'ont pas vraiment d'association
mafieuse mais des systèmes mafieux
sont très réticents et notamment aux
mots j'en parle parfois avec les
juristes de l'état de la magistrature
ils sont un peu réticents parce que
c'est vrai que ça serait parfois assez
inadaptée enfin bref il ya en revanche
une coopération judiciaire au niveau
européen comme vous savez il ya le
mandat d'arrêt européen il ya europol il
ya heureux juste l'europe s'est dotée de
structures c'est pas la difficulté
d'ailleurs c'est un peu comme dans le le
blanchiment d'argent en règle générale
il y a énormément de règles il y a
énormément de décision de deux
conventions internationales de de règles
professionnel balle de bâle iii etc mais
la réalité c'est que c'est ce qui manque
c'est les moyens pour faire appliquer
tout cela parce que
on peut heureusement fin heureusement on
va pas se doter de services répressifs
plus nombreux que le nombre de citoyens
dans chaque pays donc là là là
c'est très difficile de lutter de
manière pratique mais les instruments
juridiques
sont à peu près présent alors ils sont
beaucoup plus présents vous avez raison
en italie qu un pays comme la france où
il n'ya pas notamment par exemple une
des grandes différences entre l'italie
et la france c'est que en italie il ya
ce qu'on appelle la saisie
administrative des biens z'avaient qu'à
partir du moment où vous êtes considérés
comme faisant preuve partie d'une
association mafieuse on peut saisir sans
même une seule décision de justice vaut
bien
c'est vrai que ça peut faire réfléchir
peut faire peur en france parce que
comme il n'ya pas d'association mafieuse
alors comment on peut-on arriver à faire
des saisies administrative en france on
fait des saisies judiciaires mais elle
arrive
cinq ans plus tard voilà donc il y a des
il ya des différences et c'est vrai que
en italie l'italie est comme avec comme
les états unis le pays qui est le plus
en pointe dans le combat contre les
associations criminelle de type mafieux
et on peut penser que
petit à petit se sait la législation
italienne irriguera le reste des
législations européennes
bonsoir
je voulais poser une question sur les
lobbys
et les organisations mafieuses qui
répond à toutes les réglementations
aux états unis mais je sais par exemple
en californie
ils se sont dotés d'une organisation de
règlement sur l' influence des lobbys or
il se trouve que récemment parlement
français et c'est passé petite anecdote
d'un peu de gens pas à en parler sur
le président de la chambre a voulu
limiter l'intervention à la chambre un
certain nombre de lobbies bon et on sait
très bien qu'il y à quelques lobbys qui
sont très voisins
d'association de type mafieux
or en france il n'ya pratiquement à ma
connaissance pas grand chose qui
organise
l'intervention de ces lobbys propre et
certains de ces lobbys qui dérive
actuellement
oui alors
le lobby et la mafia c'est quand même
deux choses un peu différentes j'ai
souvent l'habitude de dire que parce que
le mot mafia et utiliser les générals
mans façon assez large il faut bien
prendre conscience quand même qu' il ya
une grande distinction entre ceux qui
ceux qui ont des pratiques que douteuse
et puis ceux qui par exemple dissolvent
les enfants dans l'acide il n'ya pas
quand même
c'est toujours il ya la mafia des
pharmaciens la mafia des jeux pas quoi
la mafia des ddd l'auguste etc c'est
quand même pas toujours la même chose
moi je me suis limité aux vrais méchants
séoul et les autres relèverait plutôt du
phénomène que cahuzac ou autres nous
font aujourd'hui traités dans
l'actualité c'est à dire les phénomènes
de corruption il est vrai il est vrai et
ça je suis absolument le premier à le
reconnaître que lorsqu'on met le pied
dans ces phénomènes là ce n'est que d
échelle de graduation c'est à dire que
nous l'avons bien vu récemment en france
par exemple un cas qui est assez
intéressant
avec la sphère de qui n'est toujours pas
jugée donc je me limite à évoquer la
chose par le biais journalistique mais
on a eu une affaire d'une élue verte qui
était prise dans une histoire de
blanchiment d'argent a priori c'était
une histoire simple de blanchiment
d'argent mais comme il est rare qu'on
fasse de blanchiment uniquement avec des
enfants de choeur on a vu qu'elle était
en fait elles utilisaient peut-être
d'ailleurs à son insu je ne sais pas
mais l'utiliser des groupes de
trafiquants de drogue qui permettaient
ces systèmes dits de compensation est en
réalité à partir du moment où on ouvre
là la vaste nébuleuse
de ce que l'on pourrait appeler
la finance criminelle on tombe sur le
moins graves jusqu'au plus grave et
c'est vrai que là il ya une graduation
qui
qui aujourd'hui en plus avec les
phénomène de mondialisation
rendent de plus en plus difficile de
distinguer bien les choses il ya le
working rich indélicats qui décide de
faire de l'évasion fiscale et puis on a
ensuite le le criminel d'entreprise qui
fait des actions par exemple de
pollution ou autre pour le profit de son
entreprise donc il est même pas lui-même
nécessairement le bénéficiaire et puis
après vous arriver vraiment haut
à la bande organisée mais bande
organisée qui parfois d'ailleurs
ne prend pas un aspect toujours mafieux
regardez les histoires qui récemment ont
égayé la chronique judiciaire pardon la
chronique financière avec les histoires
de manipulation sur le libor le le ceti
ce bon eh bien il y a eu
des des enquêtes qui avait été menée par
le le le
l'autorité
financière américain qui soulignait qu'
elle veut une sorte d' accord de cartel
de bandes organisées en réalité bon
leterme n'a pas été utilisé ainsi je
pense que là on n'est pas non plus du
tout dans des phénomènes mafieux
traditionnelle voyait est d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui on parle de mettre en place
une sorte de délit nouveau de fraude
fiscale en bande organisée j'ai entendu
ça récemment et puis alors on mais on
n'est toujours pas là dans la sphère
mafieuses et puis on a le dernier stade
du ray le stable plus criminel la
véritable bande mafieuse en france donc
le terme n'existe pas mais association
criminelle association de malfaiteurs
par donkey
est-ce que je me tromperais en disant
que dans la définition de mafia il ya
deux choses il ya
la centralisation
et la polyvalence des activités tandis
que dans les phénomènes que vous
décrivez c'est plutôt
décentralisation et
activités
précise parcellaire
bien on en était à félines
féminin c'est ça oui joutes bonsoir
d'abord je voulais vous remercier pour
votre intervention qui tout à fait
intéressante et je voulais avoir votre
avis sur ce qui est en train de se
passer en corse parce que depuis
quelques mois il ya quand même de très
nombreux décès assez traumatique et je
voulais savoir et puis en plus là je
trouve que le journalisme traite
finalement peu la question parce qu'on
ne comprend pas vraiment ce qui se passe
enfin - en tout cas donc je voulais
avoir votre avis
non je trouve que vous êtes très injuste
la belle journée c'est pas parce que je
l'étais un peu mais
non il est il la traite d'ailleurs
il la traite plutôt pas mal il ya ya ya
même des sites spécialisés sur ces
questions qui vont très très loin
voilà pour faire de la pub mais il ya
quand même des bons des bons reportages
dans l'express le point dans et puis
dans des sites spécialisés bon mais en
même temps la question est peut-être un
peu confuse pour vous comme elle l'est
pour beaucoup de gens parce que elle est
confuse s'ils voulaient c'est une
situation qui s'est terriblement
détériorés
par sous votre contrôle mais depuis les
années 90 depuis les années 90 où il ya
eu de phénomène de phénomène outre ce
que j'ai déjà mentionné c'est-à-dire
décentralisation et puis augmentation de
l'attractivité de la corse avec les prix
de l'immobilier qui ont explosé et qui
rendent évidemment beaucoup plus utile
d'aider des phénomènes de prédation
traditionnels il ya eu le fait que
la
le le le ce que l'on avait comme
obsession dans la tradition policière
française c'est le phénomène du
terrorisme ou du nationalisme disons
très violent or ce fait ce nationalisme
ou c'est terrorisme a muté dans les
années 90 et la plupart des autorités
officielles n'ont pas voulu voir ou ne
l'ont pas vu enfin bon je ne sais pas
entre l'aveuglément et le déni je serai
pas dire je penche parfois un peu pour
le déni parce que il ya eu quand même
des déclarations de certains
responsables de la lutte antiterroriste
qui font froid dans le dos je pense à
l'une d'elles notamment quand cette
personne a déclaré
la brise de mer c'est un mythe c'est
exactement ce que l'on déclarait en
sicile dans les années 60 en dix ans
bord la mafia mais ça n'existe pas c'est
juste un trait d un trait d'esprit a
trait d'humeur bon là il ya quand même
eu un aveuglement 1 jeudi au bas mot et
puis peut-être plus pourquoi parce que
comme on copie là quand il a été
question de lutter contre le terrorisme
qui était un vrai défi pour la corse le
nationaliste poser des bombes tuent et
parfois des gens et bien il ya eu des
pactes scélérat qui ont été faits
un certain nombre d'organisations plus
ou moins criminel type justement donner
des informations ou
faciliter les enquêtes de untel ou untel
d'un en contrepartie on ferme et
évidemment les yeux sur un certain
nombre d'activités et ça c'est un
phénomène très très très très classique
que j'ai écrite décrit dans le livre de
la sicile depuis le 19e siècle où il y a
eu à partir de ces pactes scélérat une
imprégnation du tissu politique
économique et sociale parce les gens du
crime organisé et ensuite vous n'en
sortez plus et vous arrivez à la
situation depuis les années 2000 2005
2006 non surtout depuis 2006 avec la
mort de jean jé colonna et et d'autres
personnages importants où il ya rupture
des équilibres criminelle et ça
défouraille dans tous les sens parce que
il y à la lutte intense pour la rente
criminelle et c'est ce phénomène qui
aujourd'hui explique que la corse est la
zone la plus criminogène d'europe
que dire de plus
merci masculin
merci bonsoir vous avez parlé ce soir de
mafia italienne sheila de mafia
italienne ma vie la corse voilà que
penser de la françafrique qui nous
concerne directement
je sais que monsieur rolland n'a reçu
hier sassou n'guesso qui est un
responsable voilà en afrique au congo
brazzaville
voilà monsieur berrou je sais que vous
avez aussi rencontré précédemment il ya
quelques temps maintenant monsieur bongo
vous avez où il ya ya ceux des années et
je lui ai ren enfin je l' ai rencontré
une fois et vous aviez indiqué vous avez
un échange personnel et de respect avec
ce monsieur je voulais savoir qu'elle
avait été là les raisons de cet échange
et pourquoi rencontrer tel personnage
rose province parce qu'il y avait de
quoi y'a des chefs d'état africains
et que c'est un continent dans lequel le
décanat comme on dit à l'université de
la fonction de doyen de plus anciens
jouent un rôle très important il m'avait
invité à passer le voir j'ai passé
un moment avec lui deux milliards sans
que d'ailleurs on se dise quoi que ce
soit de 13 des récents y avait
l'ambassadeur
et puis c'est tout je n'ai pas de jeu
n'est pas ce genre de contacts mais je
suis pas sûr que ce soit mafia au sens
que nous employons non mais papa bombe
avant la question de la françafrique
c'est très complexe et à la question
d'abord de de tout ce qu'on appelle les
kleptocrates ça c'est une autre question
que celles de la mafia c'est à dire de
tous ces chefs d'état qui peuvent être
considérées comme utilisons le
la richesse de leur pays à des fins
douteuses personnels et autres ça c'est
pas un phénomène que j'étudie parce que
c'est autre chose que la mafia mais en
revanche il ya un lien quand vous avez
parlé de la françafrique avec
moi j'utilise pas le mot mafia corse
parce que je pense pas justement que
c'est une mafia au sens strict mais donc
avec ce système corso marseillais sait
que en effet l'afrique depuis la
décentralisation a été un des lieux
majeurs
de
du développement de ce système car il
faut pas penser quand on pense qu'on dit
corse déjà les corses nerfs en iran
n'est pas tout ce que comme ça
évidemment comme les siciliens
évidemment quand on parle des siciliens
on parle pas de tous les siciliens de la
même manière quand on parle de l'accord
sont pas évidemment de tous les corses
premier point s'il ya des corses dans la
salle comme ça ça évite le
et puis deuxième chose quand on parle
des corses il ne faut jamais du fait
même de l'histoire que j'ai mentionné de
cet auteur price indiqué
particulièrement
éclaté sur l'ensemble du web les réseaux
corses étaient les premiers réseaux delà
de la mondialisation avant la lettre il
faut jamais penser corse en pensant
uniquement l'île de corse d'une part
parce que jusque dans les années en
effet jusque dans les années 70 la corse
ne représentait rien c'était juste une
île de repli
1,1 un des membres importants de la
french connection à un moment a été
poursuivi en 69 par les autorités
américaines il s'est réfugié en corse et
il a dit aux gendarmes français qu'il
était malade et qui pouvait pas répondre
aux convocations de la justice et
personne n'est allé le chercher bon
c'est une histoire assez intéressante
qui ont dit un peu long sur justement
les protections qu'ont pu parfois
bénéficier un certain nombre de ses
acteurs et donc il faut pas uniquement
se limiter à la corse il fallait penser
évidemment la région paca
toutes les anciennes colonies et puis
l'ile-de-france évidemment qu'il a été
un
et évidemment tous les corses ne sont
pas liées à cela mais il faut bien
comprendre que l'essor de la french
connection comment est comment il est né
il est né parce que marseille était la
première ville corse et que à partir des
années après le percement du canal de
suez en 1869
marseille est devenue la capitale de
tous les deux de toutes les colonies la
capitale de l'oriental à la porte du sud
comme on disait la porte de l'orient et
donc les réseaux corses se sont
implantés via les messageries maritimes
dans tous les ports importants que
desservait les messageries maritimes
c'est à dire les ports du moyen-orient
de l'inde de l'indochine de la chine
nous avions une concession française à
shanghai qui était extrêmement cruciale
puisque vous savez la chine joue un rôle
essentiel dans le trafic de l'opium et
puis ensuite
les bateaux aller aussi vers de
marseille vers l'amérique l'amérique du
nord mais aussi l'amérique du sud qui a
joué un rôle très important dans le
développement de de la french connection
on appelait ça en amérique du sud la la
corse est une connection mai donc il ya
des nébuleuses qui se sont créés dès le
début du 20e siècle et vous aviez
parfaitement raison dans ces nébuleuses
on faisait passer d'abord d'être est la
traite des femmes les piastres lors un
certain nombre les cigarettes et puis
ensuite qu'on s'est développé le marché
de la drogue ça a été la drogue mais ces
sont des tuyaux uniquement et donc il ya
eu des implantations un peu partout
je voudrais quand même ajouter un mot en
réponse à ce que vous avez dit monsieur
parce que j'ai j'ai rassemblé mes
souvenirs en même temps
c'était un moment extrêmement précis
j'étais crédiblement sur le point de
remporter l'élection présidentielle
française
et quand vous remportez l'élection
présidentielle française nature enfin
quand vous êtes en situation crédible
peut-être hypothétiquement fin crédible
de l'emporter vous devez rencontrer les
chefs d'état
du monde entier ou en tout cas avant
tout petit peu bon c'est à ce titre
qu'il ya eu cette rencontre j'ai
maintenant prononcé une phrase
dont chacun des termes sera pesée par
vous une chose est de les rencontrer
une chose est d'accepter
de se mettre
dans leurs mains
et d'avoir des dettes de reconnaissance
envers eux
et sur ce deuxième point je puis vous
rassurer entièrement
bonsoir
oui mais
l'alternance masculin féminin
alors ma question concerne la place du
citoyen dans l'homme
donc dans dans la mafia
pensez vous qu en rééduquant la
population qui finalement être plutôt
passive la rendant peut-être plus
participative est ce qu'il y aurait
moyen d'agir est ce que c'est un moyen
d'action on entend souvent de la part du
citoyen que fait la police que fait la
mairie
c'est ce genre de de remarquer en temps
mais le citoyen en tant que tels que
peut-il faire
c'est un petit peu la question est ce
que la lutte contre les phénomènes
mafieux et là ça vaut aussi pour les
systèmes de type mafieux et ne peut pas
se limiter à une réponse répressive
parce que vous savez qu'en corse et le
lille où il ya le plus de policiers par
habitant je crois que c'est le doubs le
la plupart des autres régions françaises
c'est pas ça qui résout le problème
c'est si vous avez parfaitement raison
on ne peut véritablement lutter contre
un phénomène qui n'est pas seulement un
phénomène de délinquance mais un
phénomène qui touche à la l'essence même
de notre vivre ensemble c'est à dire ce
phénomène mafieux en se limitant
uniquement à la police et à la justice
tout doit être mobilisée alors compte
beaucoup par exemple des services de
l'administration traditionnelle par
exemple et à juste titre d'ailleurs
quand j'ai valls est allé dans l'île il
a dit on va mobiliser l'inspection des
finances
les inspecteurs des impôts locaux etc
les phénomènes les administrations
sociales les administrations fiscales
les administrations
les hypothèques etc tout cela compte
beaucoup et puis il ya évidemment la
société civile qui pose un énorme
problème parce que évidemment un
phénomène mafieux réel ça phénomène qui
vit essentiellement par la peur
qu'ils imposent aux autres il ya une
certaine délicatesse en revanche de
valse de culpabiliser un peu les corses
ont leur disant maintenant faut arrêter
cette culture de l'eau mais retard mais
l'omerta c'est pas une culture
contrairement d'ailleurs à ce que
veulent faire croire les les
mafieux eux mêmes l'omerta c'est la
conséquence de la peur on ne parle pas
parce qu'on a peur est souvent hélas on
a raison d'avoir peur alors
là
se joue de deux choses il faut
évidemment donc essayer de faire changer
la peur de camp mais ça c'est lié
vraiment une réponse simplement
répressive et puis il faut aussi
faire changer les esprits de la plupart
des gens qui vivent sous cette
domination mafieuses et qui sont
accommode car je ne sais pas si vous
avez remarqué mais au moment où il ya eu
tous ces attentats c'est assassinat en
corse en octobre novembre et ses
terrains il ya eu pas mal de reportages
locaux et j'ai moi-même eu à discuter
avec un certain nombre de corses et j'ai
eu affaire a parfois des réponses du
genre ah mais nous on n'a jamais dénoncé
des juifs durant la guerre on va pas s'y
mettre maintenant ou à bas ici de toute
façon c'est normal c'est la tradition
c'est la culture du silence etc ça c'est
un phénomène que l'on a très bien connu
en sicile jusque dans les années 70
c'est l'acceptation de la violence
larvée si vous voulez de la domination
mafieuses et en effet et là vous avez
parfaitement raison ce n'est que quand
l'opinion publique arrive véritablement
a bien cerné l'ordre des réalités à bien
comprendre ce qu'est un système de
l'égalité à bien réagir par rapport à
tous les phénomènes dont elle est
environné en protestant en trouvant
anormal que tout ce qui est en dehors
des règles de des règles de droit
traditionnel ne pas considérer ça comme
normal parce qu'ici c'est pas les règles
normales de l'état qu'on respecte et
c'est enfin j'espère être clair
quand il y à une prise de conscience
qu'il faut réagir et faire affirmé la
légalité par rapport à tout ce qui est
l'illégalité ou la dérive mafieuse à ce
moment là il ya déjà un pas en avant
considérable qui est fait et c'est ce
que l'on constate aujourd'hui par
exemple en sicile la ccyn est loin de là
elle n'a pas mené n'a pas fini avec le
phénomène mafieux parce que hélas
jusqu'à présent dans l'histoire il n'ya
pas un seul exemple lorsqu il y a eu
l'implantation d'un réel phénomène
mafieux sur un territoire on ait pu
l'éradiquer définitivement ce qui
d'ailleurs pose beaucoup d'inquiétude
pour ce certaines régions dont vous êtes
de quel côté on veut parler mais en même
temps on peut le diminuer on peut le
rendre marginal on peut
disons faire en sorte qu' il ne soit
plus aussi
prépondérant et prépotence qu'il ne
l'est
lorsqu'il n'ya pas cette prise de
conscience de la société civile vous
donne un exemple
en italie il ya une très grande
décentralisation
aussi bien sur le plan
politique que sur le plan syndical et et
notamment dans l'éducation il y a
énormément de rencontres avec les
auteurs dans les écoles et autres
il n'est pas rare de trouver encore
aujourd'hui dans la région de naples ou
dans la région de ou en calabre des
jeunes filles à qui on le maître d'école
de monnaies qu'est ce que vous voulez
faire plus tard et qui répondent femme
de bosses
parce que c'est un peu comme femmes de
footballeurs quoi c'est vraiment
une réussite bon eh bien aujourd'hui en
sicile j'en ai fait récemment
l'expérience il n'y a plus de jeunes
filles qui vous disent je veux être
femme de bosses parce que le combat de
la légalité et quand même
a réussi à porter ses fruits et il y a
toujours des enfants qui un petit de
manière cachée rêve probablement de
devenir la femme du boss ou d'être le
boss lui même mais ça ne se dit plus il
y a plus cette volonté
c'est ce n'est plus un signe de réussite
c'est plutôt quelque chose que que l'on
fini par
assumer parce qu'on peut pas faire autre
chose voilà bref pardonnez moi mais
c'est en effet essentiel que la société
civile se mobilise et qu'elle ne reste
pas au niveau d'une société un civil qui
étaient là ce que l'on voit de plus en
plus dans certaines régions
merci beaucoup je vais prendre la
dernière question ce que leurs atours
n'est même plus que je ne croyais
mais je veux vous raconter une anecdote
avant précisément sur ce thème l'un
j'étais à midi aux grandes gueules de
rmc
une mission très intéressante mais il y
avait juste avant moi avec les vraies
grandes gueules à moi j'étais dans la
partie civilisé
il y avait un débat très intéressant sur
ce sujet parce que à bordeaux
il y a un groupe dans un
quartier réputé difficile il ya un
groupe qui s'est mis en tête d'avoir une
action
directe contre les dealers ils ont
décidé qu'ils les photographier avec
leur portable et qu'il mettait les
photos des échanges des deals sur
facebook
je sais pas ce qu'il faut en penser mais
je me suis dit qu'il y avait là quelque
chose
peut-être
c'est c'est à proscrire en tout cas
c'est il ya une réflexion à conduire
dans beaucoup de quartiers j'entends
dire laissez nous faire des milices bien
sûr c'est pas ça le fait pas salle but
mais il ya des gens qu'ils pensent
il ya des gens qu'ils pensent mais
l'idée que
rien qu'avec ça et facebook vous pouvez
créer un certain nombre de situations
pour inverser la pression
ce soit plus une pression subie
sur leur part la société venant d'eux
crime organisé mais au contraire une
pression renversé qui peut être discrète
il ya là quelque chose qui est pas qui
est pas totalement absurde et en tout
cas ça va donner matière à réflexion ou
plutôt ça va donner matière à dire là il
ya un sujet de réflexion mais les
sociologues
pourront sur ce sujet
abondamment avancé à la
probablement plus facile à bordeaux qu'à
marseille mais on sait jamais vous savez
il ya
le courage n'est pas si fréquent qu'on
croit mais il n'est pas totalement
absent non plus surtout s'il peut être
discret
heureuse les nations qui n'ont pas
besoin de héros
mais nous nous avons peut-être
va l'aj auxerre qui disait tu jean
pierre qui a levé le doigt dit foire
qui sa
magie
laurent
bonsoir bonsoir simplement pour finir
peut-être
franchir l'atlantique est allée du
peut-être du côté des etats-unis du
canada qui est connu il ya il ya un an
justement une problématique mafieuse
importants dont on a parlé avec avec un
avec un procès avec un certain nombre de
deux personnes dans les travaux publics
et je voudrais avoir votre sentiment
justement à la fois sur le mafieux au
canada et peut-être c'est sûr sur
l'ensemble du continent nord américain
ça ne nécessiterait évidemment plusieurs
heures la commission charbonneau à
laquelle vous faites référence à est
très intéressante à regarder parce que
elle confirme exactement ce que ce que
je disais c'est à dire que l analyse un
phénomène qui est très ancien en réalité
au canada vous savez l'implantation des
mafia sicilienne et calabraise à la
région de montréal remonte aux années 30
et s'est surtout développée à partir des
années 50 donc c'est pas quelque chose
d'ancien d'un nouveau pardon mais on le
découvre un peu plus maintenant pour
différentes raisons et la commission
charbonneau qui a étudié donc ce
phénomène d'implantation mafieuse donc
de contrôler le territoire et
d'insertion dans les dents les résidents
les
dans les marchés mais pas seulement des
travaux publics mais en particulier
travaux publics eh bien il fait ce
constat très étonnant et c'est lié
notamment au retrait de l'état c'est à
dire qu'il ya énormément de pratiques de
dit daoud sourcing dans les veaux lui
par le management les théories du
management contemporain c'est à dire
qu'on a énormément
sortie de la sphère publique de beaucoup
de marchés pour les attribuer à des
entreprises privées on a dépouillé enfin
dépouillé disons que les gens les
fonctionnaires sont partis parce qu'il
n'était pas bien payés ou que de toute
façon ce n'est pas à la mode puis il ya
eu aussi des réductions d'effectifs du
coup ce que souligne la commission
charbonneau c'est que pourquoi y ait
autant de corruption dans les travaux
publics mais tout simplement parce qu'il
n'y avait plus personne pour les
contrôler ou les peu de personnes qui
restent n avait aucun moyen ni humain ni
juridique d'ailleurs pour les contrôler
parce que là les mécanismes de la
cellule liée avec le lien avec le
néolibéralisme c'est à dire que plus on
dépouille l'état - on le rend capable
aussi de lutter contre ces phénomènes
est donc cette cette situation souligne
et je le répète encore ne s'est pas une
libération d'un quelqu'un qui serait pas
content
avec le néolibéralisme c'est une réalité
évoqué par cette commission c'est que on
a évidemment dans l'est en amérique du
nord des phénomènes aussi considérable
d'implantation mafieuses en partie pour
cette raison je donne un dernier point
très bref c'est l'implantation donc la
mafia sicilienne et d'ailleurs pas
uniquement cécilienne des mafias
italiennes en amérique du nord remonte
donc voilà ce qu'on appelle la première
mondialisation avec ce qu'elle appelait
de suzanne burger la première
mondialisation c'est-à-dire dès les
années 1880
les les deux grandes vagues
d'immigration italienne
en amérique c'est aux états unis dans
les années 1880 et en argentine
aux états unis capitalisme sauvage dans
les années 1880
ce qu'on a appelé donc apte et soulage
les mafia sicilienne se sont implantés
sans aucune difficulté
il n'y en a pas eu en argentine jusqu'à
récemment
parce que le contexte politico
administratif n'était pas du tout le
même
merci beaucoup sous vos applaudissements
jean-pierre vous savez qui nous
accueillons menace la prochaine fois
l'histoire n'a aucune importance
chaque jeudi pour ce qu'aime histoire
ils peuvent lire jacques de saint victor
dans le figaro littéraire
alors nous accueillons voilages et prend
le micro le 23 avril jean-paul betbèze
qui est le chef économie si je comprends
bien de de crédit agricole
il n'est plus sûr et moins très bien
donc il a tout loisir pour venir parler
avec nous on l'invite parce que il
publie une tribune libre chez plon un
livre assez intéressant elle pas
seulement économique si je puis dire
halte honneur économique mais politique
aussi finalement si ça nous arrivait
demain
merci simplement pour vous dire deux
choses d'abord je suis tout de même
heureux je me disais ça pendant cette
rencontre je connais pas de parti
politique qui soit capable d'organiser
comme ça des réflexions aussi suivi
passionnante autour de sujets aussi
sans trop large et éloigné de débat
politique enfin éloignées
qui au moment où nous les avons convoqué
par s est éloigné de l'actualité voilà
donc
et
c'est la deuxième fois qu'il viendra
voilà merci beaucoup et dernier point
dernier point avant que on se sépare le
et s'est pas totalement étranger le site
moralisation point fr qui soutient
l'idée qu'il y a des pas dans la
régulation de l'activité publique qui ne
pourront être fait que si on dépasse le
système parlementaire classique et si on
fait un texte soumis aux citoyens
approche les 50 mille signatures qu'est
donc
si si vous pouvez le répercuter sur vos
réseaux personal ça serait très bien
parce que
voyez que c'est un très grand sujet
si l'on considère que ces régulations ne
peuvent relever que du réseau classique
il ya des décisions qui ne seront jamais
prises j'ai cité comme exemple par
exemple la diminution du nombre de
députés de sénateurs ne sera jamais
prise par les députés et sénateurs en
place et donc si on veut le conduire ça
veut dire qu'il faut avoir en tête que
la responsabilisation des citoyens est
un phénomène très important j'ajoute
pour ajouter à l'arrêt à la réflexion
que c'est un parti pris alors absolument
optimiste en face de ce qu'on entend
habituellement 2
du fond de l'air qui dit mais un
référendum vous pouvez pas le gagner en
période de crise les gens répondent non
ça dépend ce qu'on leur demande ben
parce que je suis sûr qu'un grand nombre
de citoyens sur des sujets comme ça
pourrait être qu'après après tout c'est
leur responsabilité
mais si on leur offre pas ils pourront
pas s'en saisir il pourrait être capable
de porter plus loin la volonté que un
grand nombre d'entre eux expriment en
privé mais qui est interdite dans le
débat public et donc je le disais aussi
pour internet moralisation point fr et
ça marche très bien si ça marche pas
vous recommencez parce que c'est
quelquefois la deuxième ou troisième
fois parce que le site est parfois
bloqués merci à tous et merci à jacques
de saint victor